today
via trade that sent teddy bridgewater
the last pick in round one 2014 the
johnny manziel draft
now from carolina to denver goes teddy
bridgewater sixth round pick for the
panthers in 2021 they get back sort of
the sixth round pick they gave to the
new york jets as part of the sam darnold
deal and the panthers
they're paying seven million dollars of
teddy bridgewater's salary because it
was due to make 17 million 10 million of
it guaranteed the panthers save three
million get a sixth round pick unload
the salary of 17 million and the broncos
get a quarterback now to compete with
drew locke
and look miles i think the bottom line
is even though the panthers have added
sam darnold and the broncos have now had
a teddy bridgewater
both teams i think are still in play for
quarterbacks with eight and nine
respectively there just isn't the
urgency that there would have been and
maybe they don't have to worry about
getting leapfrogged the way they would
have had to have worried about it before
they made these trades
sure look the
i think if you're talking about guys
like teddy bridgewater sam darnold and
drew locke you're not talking about the
upper echelon of qb's in this league
right so i don't know i mean i tweeted
it out today like that gif of larry
david at the end of the palestinian
chicken episode of curb your enthusiasm
where he's looking to his left and to
his right and he's saying oh no like
what am i going to choose here that to
me is like the quarterback competition
between drew locke and teddy bridgewater
i'm it doesn't excite me you know if i'm
a broncos fan i guess we got better
today maybe i i think you know when you
look at what uh george payton said in
that release that they had to announce
the trade for teddy bridgewater he said
he brings competition and experience
does that really sound like something
you really want out of a qb just
competition and experience sounds like a
backup and really when you're only
paying him three million dollars because
as you just said the panthers are kind
of paying seven million dollars for him
to go away you're paying him as if he's
a backup anyway so like you said mike
this is not it's not something that
should take the broncos out of uh the
competition from selecting a quarterback
in the first round if somebody starts to
slip and fall
maybe they trade up a couple spots to
try to leapfrog the panthers if the
panthers also seem like they like that
qb as well but i just i don't feel like
this is something
that really makes the broncos super
super competitive and we're talking
about trading quarterbacks for sixth
round picks here you know it just it is
what it is and i think that the broncos
are gonna be fine with teddy bridgewater
if they play him but i don't know that
they're gonna be that much better than
if they just stuck with drew locke
final bill for the broncos will actually
be 4.5 million because teddy's salary is
11.5 he cut from 17 to 11.5 panthers pay
seven a uh 4.5 is the difference that's
a bargain that's peanuts as quarterbacks
go
and he could be the backup he could be
the starter
he could be
the guy who is a placeholder for whoever
they would draft or he competes with
drew locke it's a bunch of different
things potentially but he's going to
make 11.5 million which is better than
if he had dug in his heels in carolina
refused to cut his pay and eventually
gotten cut because his maximum
compensation that way would have been 10
million because the panthers would have
owed him 10 and they would have gotten
an offset for whatever he made elsewhere
and no one was going to pay him more
than 10 as evidenced by the fact that
carolina pays seven and denver pays 4.5
so it works out well it's a win-win for
the two teams and it's a win for teddy
bridgewater even though it remains to be
seen whether he will actually play and
george payton was the assistant gm in
minnesota when bridgewater was drafted
they loved him in minnesota his career
there went off the rails because of that
fluke acl tear from late august to 2016
and then he was a backup
in new orleans and before that he was
actually with the jets he signed with
the jets he was their placeholder until
they got sam darnold and was with the
jets into the pre-season there are
photos and it's weird to see it of teddy
bridgewater in a jets uniform next to
sam darnold in a jets uniform and yes
teddy bridgewater has been
traded twice in his career and both
times were because of sam darnold
because darnold is present and now teddy
moves on so
that's uh
that was expected though from the moment
that
the the panthers traded for sam daughter
we expected that teddy bridgewater was
going to be gone the question was when
and and here's an interesting point
miles from timing standpoint
and this is why i think the broncos did
it as a measure of insurance against the
possibility
of not getting a guy at number nine
because if you have teddy
maybe there is a greater chance that
that guy falls to you if you wait to
pick up teddy later number one you may
have to give up more maybe the panthers
want
more if you didn't take a quarterback in
round one i thought it would come
between round one and two a trade of
teddy bridgewater but uh the timing to
me is interesting because the broncos
pulled the trigger a day before round
one not the day after round one
yeah that does make it interesting and
we've been talking about that i feel
like for the last few weeks i mean ever
since teddy bridgewater excuse me the
panthers acquired uh sam darnold it
seemed like teddy bridgewater was going
to be traded and the broncos were always
a team that came up in the conversation
because of the connection with george
payton in minnesota and also i mean
you've got pat shurmur who was also
there
in minnesota as an offensive coordinator
and now he reunites there with teddy
bridgewater too so there's there's a lot
of different connections and that should
make things fairly easy for teddy
bridgewater to come in and learn the
offense and get acclimated and all that
and you know what george payton has
talked about is making sure they have
competition at quarterback for drew
locke so if nothing else they do have
that competition now how good of a
competition is it i don't really know
but i think that the point is they have
at least ensured themselves that yes
they do have somebody at quarterback so
they don't have to force picking a qb or
maybe try to trade up a little bit more
than they would otherwise if they see
somebody that they like that's falling i
think it's good insurance it's probably
good business for them to pick up
somebody like teddy bridgewater but it
sure should not take them out of the
conversation for picking up somebody who
they truly believe can be a franchise qb
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports